a new effort to control the global
coronavirus pandemic
president biden says that the u.s will
donate 25 million doses of surplus
vaccine
to the united nations to use in
countries that badly need them
now there's also a big push to get more
people vaccinated in this country
the biden administration is focusing on
states with the lowest vaccination rates
to find ways to give more shots to more
americans
maria villarreal is in an underserved
area of birmingham alabama
a state where less than one third of the
population is fully vaccinated boy
that's scary to hear maria
what are officials telling you there
well good morning gail right now they
are saying demand is
down and it's not from a lack of access
now this site this mass vaccination site
is run by the university of alabama
at birmingham but basically they've run
five different mass vaccination sites
just like this they've said people have
stopped coming so right now they are
down to two
sites that are set to close in the next
few weeks combined total on any given
day they're only seeing
about 200 people come in for their shots
three months ago the parker high school
vaccination site near birmingham was
bustling with activity now it's a much
quieter scene we've what unfortunately
gone from seeing crowded parking lots
with
mass vaccine sites to empty parking lots
dr
sarah nafsiger is the vice president of
clinical support services
for the university of alabama at
birmingham which runs this site
how does that even happen what's the
hesitancy here you know i wish i knew
the answer to that question people have
a lot of questions about the safety and
there are some people who just you know
i think will not be convinced
jessica webber had safety concerns of
her own but
finally got the shot thursday any reason
why you waited so long
i think it was just kind of figuring it
out see how everybody was doing with
it um you know we're looking to
hopefully expand our family and there
was some stuff without fertility but
we've
talked to our doctor so we knew it was
the right step for us and for our family
and to help
keep these guys safe there is ongoing
misinformation
about the covenant team vaccines
impairing fertility
certainly these vaccines do not dr karen
landers is the alabama assistant state
health officer
she says misinformation is driving
hesitancy
especially among young people we are
concerned that even if we get through
this summer with relatively low rates
that we
could see an increase in the fall again
our health care system did a great job
being able to manage and take care of
kobe patients
but we do not want to go back there in
alabama and as i tell everyone when i'm
speaking about this
we have a way out of this and it's
called vaccine
and as uab winds down its mass
vaccination sites
nafsiger says they're pivoting to
community pop-ups and direct outreach
whatever it takes to reach those still
on the sidelines
we came in with the sledgehammer
approach and now we're getting a lot
more refined we're not going to stop
until we get this job done
by july all of the mass vaccination
sites will be closed and they'll go to a
more targeted approach and
in this state they're also doing vaccine
incentives the way only people in the
south could do and i'm from the south
so i can say that here in alabama if you
get your shot
you win an opportunity to possibly drive
your vehicle
on the talladega super speedway let me
tell you i've already gotten my vaccine
but i am thinking about it anthony
i'm thinking about giving it a shot i
think you should i think that's a great
incentive up there with uh
up there with donuts that i've heard
that some people here have already
cashed in on
maria thank you make sure there's video